overall
this is Star Talk a very special edition
we are celebrating the 10th anniversary
of Felix bumgardner's Red Bull jumped
from the edge of the stratosphere
where he fell and accelerated to faster
than the speed of sound
long before he would later deploy his
parachute setting a record
for the highest free fall jump ever yeah
we've got him we're going to reminisce
about what was going on in his head when
he took the jump the physics of free
fall when you jump out of a balloon and
a little bit of the physiology of it too
and that will happen on this special
one-on-one explainer edition of Star
Talk
[Music]
Felix welcome dude hey what up everyone
thanks for having me on your show me I'm
very excited wow so I can't believe it
was 10 years ago because it feels like
yesterday uh does it feel like yesterday
for you
no not at all
very good if you just hanging around on
your couch maybe it feels like it was
yesterday but I was I was doing a lot of
things the last 10 years you know I
don't even know where to start but busy
guys so let's just let's just get the
fundamentals of that jump back in front
of us all so you head on a pressurized
suit uh look very much like a moon suit
of some kind it has to keep the air
pressure and temperature regulated and
you were brought Aloft in a balloon is
that correct yeah all the way up to 130
000 feet a hundred and thirty has any
human being ever existed at that
elevation who was not otherwise in an
airplane or a rocket well airplanes
don't don't fly that high Rockets of
course they do you know people have been
on the moon that's way higher actually
it's on another planet but as far as I
know as far as I remember nobody has
seen higher and it's the biggest balloon
ever launched in history and here's an
interesting fact I think people don't
always know or think about the size of
the balloon
at 130 000 feet is very different from
the size of the balloon when you left
Earth's surface could you just comment
on that well the thing is when you
launch it you know you have to keep in
mind what's it's thinner than a sandwich
bag which makes the balloon very fragile
it's it's very delicate you know so even
putting the balloon out of the box and
then you lay it
parallel to the runway is already
difficult you know you cannot pull on
the balloon because you go damage the
material a little bit and then it it
creates a malfunction on on launch you
know so once you fill it up with helium
it's like a giant sausage you know with
a little bit of a helium bottle on top
and once you you'll launch it you know
the higher you go the less outside
pressure you have that means the balloon
with the ascent will expand you know and
that at a scattering altitude at 130 000
feet it's like a giant ball you know it
looks completely different uh versus
when when it has left the ground so it's
very interesting to look at it and you
it was very reasonable from the ground
people could see oh my gosh oh
interesting because normally if some
planes at 130 000 feet you don't see
them at all they're they're completely
too small and invisible so you so all
right it's one thing to go up on a
balloon it's another thing to abandon it
in place it just jump so you know we've
heard this saying uh when asked you know
some people say uh uh will you ever
Skydive and they'll say no I will never
jump out of a perfectly good airplane
implying that if something's wrong if
something's wrong with the plane of
course you're going to want to jump out
of it you don't want to crash with it so
you had a perfectly good balloon that
you jumped out of so what's was this
just to set a record or is there some
other motive or or or driver for this
you know first of all when you look at
my bank my background
um I did a lot of Base jumps around the
world a lot of them have been illegally
you know our best jumped off the cheese
statue in Rio de Janeiro
um the proteins Twin Towers in Kuala
Lumpur a basically of the highest
building at that time in 2007 that
Taipei 101 Financial Center in Taiwan so
iconic these are iconic structures right
yeah it's not just a high place it's a
high important place that's why I've
selected those those options and just
remind I'm a city kid just tell me what
base jumping means
base jumping is is a special form of
stat having it means you're jumping from
fixed object space does not stand for
base it stands for B like building a
antenna Tire s span like Bridges and
ease or
this is what bass stands for I never
knew that okay and and you have a
parachute or some kind of a gliding
parachute correct you have a base
parachute which is special to sign
parachute it opens faster and also it
was also a different way to pack it to
make it open faster it's only one
parachute Because by the time when you
open the parachute you're already so low
a second parachute would not help so
that's the difference between a regular
skydiver and a base jumper we only use
one parachute didn't know that okay so
uh because they they're you can steer it
I think right you have some control over
where you go are you susceptible to
updrafts that could sort of that'll
enable your your flight to persist
longer than otherwise not really it's
not like paragliding I do that as well
but Power betting is way bigger
parachute or power guide it's completely
made out of a different fabric you know
it has less air that goes through it
that's why you can use thermals you can
use the updraft but not on a base
jumping you know of course you it's it's
their wind is a factor especially on
opening because you have the wind is
coming from the wrong side it will turn
your parachute around we call this off
heading opening that means it's
especially when you do buildings you
know and it turns a partial of the round
180 degrees you hit the building the car
should collapse and they most likely die
because when you start base jumping I
don't mean to laugh but you you describe
this so calmly well if it turns around
and you you hit the building and die
that's what it is so it all depends on
your pack job you know and on making the
right judgment you know sometimes the
when the wind is not to your favor you
have to call it off this is your
insurance
okay so but in this jump however it's
not a base jump it's not a Skydive you
actually were in free fall uh for some
amount of time until you ultimately did
open a parachute so what was the we're
glad you did that because
okay
um so what talk me through what it is to
free fall through thin air but the air
is getting thicker and thicker so you
would hit some maximum speed before the
air slowly brought you back down to what
we all know is like the terminal
velocity of a body falling through the
atmosphere well the thing is if you go
all the way up to 130 000 feet the air
is so thin because the molecules are so
far apart and it means the air allows
you to travel so fast you know that's
why we selected that altitude there's
hardly any air resistance at that point
it's almost like a vacuum right okay so
that's the reason why we went all the
way up to 130 000 feet and once you step
off you accelerate so fast so within 50
seconds 50 seconds just think about this
I was accelerating to 890 miles an hour
which is equivalent to Mach 1.25 so Mach
1 is supersonic speed but I was
even get faster than supersonic speed
Mach 1.25 it's it's faster than a bullet
you know it's pretty pretty fast okay so
is that was that the velocity where and
you've Fallen far enough where the air
is now slowly trying to slow you down
again exactly so at the 90 000 seats
there's a thicker layer of air comes in
very Progressive so you can feel it you
know so before it's thin air there's
almost no resistance which also means at
the same time all your scattering skills
that I developed the last 30 years are
pretty much useless because you have no
resistance you cannot use the air to
your own Advantage you you live that but
we see that in movies where someone
jumps second and the person ahead of
them their parachute didn't open up so
then they they they do into a straight
dive to minimize their air resistance
they catch up and then they open up
again so I think we've seen this and
this is what you're describing none of
that's available to you in extremely
thin air that's your point that's the
problem so that means you have to be
really patient for a while until you hit
a layer of thick air and then you're
scattering skills are coming back into
play and now you can use your skydiving
skills to position yourself
and that happens within around 90 000
feet
okay and so then you slowly slow down
until I guess you know the air keeps
getting thicker and it keeps slowing you
down and so at the point you deployed
your parachute how fast were you going
well at the very end it's just a regular
Skydive and around 5000 feet you know I
was deploying my parachuting that's like
a regular sketch okay and so will you go
in 100 200 miles an hour about that
perhaps
oh 200 miles an hour is too fast I don't
know I'm playing miles but um I would
say 120. this America Jack we do miles
here yeah that's the problem you know I
always have to convert this in Austin I
have to think about all those numbers
exactly thank you for converting as much
as you've done even thus far in this
podcast uh so uh so this was not just a
casual thing you did this was a an
internet sensation at the time correct
me if I'm wrong it was the most live
most watched streamed event ever on
YouTube is that correct that is true
it's interesting because yesterday I was
on in another TV show with Claude Ruby
you know he's he was the former YouTube
boss at that time and he was in charge
when they broadcasted my jump from
Stratosphere life back in 2012. and back
in 2012 it was a complete different game
to broadcast something at that size
because they originally thought there's
a maximum four or five hundred thousand
people will dial in at the same time but
then once the balloon has left with
every foot that was going higher the
numbers getting higher and higher one
million two million three million they
were hanging out at Google Hangout you
know and they looked at each other like
where is this gonna go because they knew
at around 4 million people
they thought their server will collapse
and it was like it was very interesting
because you know
we're both sitting in the same Hot Seat
you know I knew I have to deliver
because the whole world is watching he
knew he has to deliver because the whole
world wanted to watch and if we both
fail he's most likely losing his job and
I will lose my life you know so at that
point we're both stressed out but
luckily it worked you know I could
finish mascara and they never stopped
broadcasting so was your record has your
record broken been broken broken since
then
the altitude record did only two years
later Ellen used this
so how come how come I know about you
but I don't know about him
that's a good question it's an easy
answer because most of the people
um don't remember this because we did it
live you know and he just strapped a
couple of cameras on on his suit and
they they showed it on the next day and
you know if you see something live it
really burns into your brain for the
rest of your life because it's very
interesting to watch it it's it's
nerve-wracking as you probably remember
and that's the required
not a lot not a lot of people remember
Ellen Eustis you know but it was still a
good jump I mean he had a different
approach instead of a capsule he was not
using a capsule and it was just attached
with his suit he was a different type of
suit it's called an Eva external
vehicular activity suit which is pretty
much a capsule with arms and legs you
know very bulky you had to bring him on
a stroller because you cannot walk in
that suit and then they released him two
kilometers a couple thousand feet higher
or some other device he was hanging on a
balloon okay much smaller balloon
because
the fact that they're not having a
capsule means they get rid of a lot of
weight it means they could use a way
smaller balloon which oh you should
launch and that smaller balloon of
course grows higher right of course
they're released it manually from the
ground
and then he was using it Rogue so as
soon as he got released
they fired the globe Chute which is kind
of a stabilization shoot so he was
riding all the way down in free fall on
a stabilization shoot
and that has two meanings that means he
could not
fall as fast as I did and the second
thing is he does not apply for the same
record
um okay because it's not a free fall
it's it's not not that unaided Free Fall
because it's an aided Free Fall you know
with it using a stabilization device and
that's a different category so taking
this jump you're doing things that you
hadn't done before with all of your base
jumping and so tell me what role Joe
kittinger played in this I read about
him briefly but tell me who he was to
you
Joel first of all
it's great a Great Character man that
guy is is a tough cookie I have to say
that you know
very stubborn sometimes military
backgrounds very interesting character
but also a lot of fun it has such a
great sense of humor and everybody Lost
the show that's why he was an important
role on the team not because of his
great sense of humor of course that
helps it helps you know because it
brings up um a lot of good emotions of
course something so difficult so
sometimes humor really helps especially
in those dark times you know where
nothing is moving forward
but also show Proud a lot to the table
because he did something very similar
back in the 60s he did a skydive from
101 000 feet back in the 60s you know
just think about this right right what I
really admire until you have to give a
lot of credit to Joe at that time he
only had 33 skydives on his belt and I
remember when I had 33 Scout apps I
could barely make it out of an airplane
you know so we're standing there with
his spacesuit you know on an open
Gondola it had just had some curtains to
block this the sunlight you know and
then he did it you know he he was of
course did not break the speed of sound
but it was very close and he was an
important asset because the only one
being there done that and he helped me
so much not only on the developing
process also on the actual day when I
was sitting in that capsule
that deep coming voice that choking at
your head oh wow guiding me all the way
up because I'm sitting here you know
it's not an easy attached because
there's just so many things that you
have to do you know
um you're doing something you never did
before and also at the same time the
whole world is watching so it's not just
the physics of it it's and the
physiologists psychology there's a
mental the psychology you know yeah and
then listening to somebody's voice and
Joe has a really cool deep voice it's
very interesting to listen to I'm a very
calming voice and of course you trust
Joe because you know this is the only
person on the planet
who know what it means you know who know
what it takes because he has done this
because he has done the same thing 50
years ago sitting in the same capsule or
in a very similar capsule going all the
way up to 101 000 feet so that is a real
pattern here to me so I'm told that he
was uh part of his experiments were to
see what might happen to Mercury
astronauts uh if they were to eject too
high up I mean this is not just he
didn't do it just to just for grins
right he didn't know yeah there was a it
was an assignment right it was a
military project called manhai and was
what they did is um before going to the
Moon they had to find out
um it's a high altitude bailout and and
safe re-entry back to Earth possible you
know they were testing spacesuits we're
testing all kinds of stuff because you
know it was one important step or one
important piece of apostle on the way to
the Moon you know Joe keita just signed
up for this it was a former Air Force
Scandal we served in Vietnam
um I he also got shut down you know so
he has a really interesting background
but it never broke show he never
launched his great sense of humor he's a
very adorable human being well a shout
out to Joe just oh yeah as part of
American history and just uh oh boy hi
I'd love that the name of that program
man hi
philosophical here would did you this is
the highest altitude at which you've
ever observed Earth's surface did you
feel any different just standing there
before you took the jump or or were you
too revved up that there was no time for
philosophizing
no well you know I'm
I started skydiving when I was 17 years
old so my journey to the stratosphere
already started at that time without
knowing you know it just jumped out of
an aircraft of a perfectly fine aircraft
like you said Each of 17. um it was a
childhood dream and this was the moment
where everything started and then I
became a military power trooper and I
was always interested in skydiving then
started in 86 in in 96 I started base
jumping so all those different steps
have been important to develop skills to
develop a relationship with Red Bull
um to get confident and then later on
when I signed up for ripple Stratos it
was interesting to me because in all
those space jumps that I did at a
certain point I kind of felt like I'm
constantly repeating myself so I wanted
to to do something different you know
and also I have to say after 9 11 it was
not so cool anymore to trash tests and
then sneak into buildings and that kind
of stuff it became
not cool anymore you know after 9 11 so
we had to change beers and that's why I
signed up for Rebel Stratos and this was
a completely different game because now
I have to become a team player you know
before as a base jumper it's a very
simple relationship it's me my parachute
my decision making
yeah but on on Red Bull Stratos there's
just so many people involved you know
and sometimes you go into a meeting with
four problems and then you leave that
meeting with another four problems on
top of it and no solution so it's very
frustrating and originally we thought
it's just going to take two years that
we ended up working five years on this
program speaking of the World Trade
Center if you look in our archives of
star talk we actually interviewed
Philippe Petit and I was just a man on
Wire yeah yeah it was around the time
that the movie came out right right yeah
and it was betraying I'm a big fan and
just to see what effort it took to just
basically sneak in like you were saying
and then and send a rope across to the
other side so that you can then I mean
it required a lot of subterfuge to make
to make that happen uh so are there
anyone who has tried this before but
just died and so no one's talking about
them yeah uh Nick pientena
you know it's very difficult name he was
a truck driver and it was the first
non-military person person trying to
break choking's record Nick pientinares
yeah I was just wondering because
they're people uh we're just coming
through Columbus today here in the
United States and
um Columbus is remembered right for all
that he did or didn't do but he's
remembered and he came across in the
middle of hurricane season yet there was
no hurricane okay so I'm just I'm just
wondering whether how about Arnold
schmednick did he try to cross the ocean
and is now at the bottom of the ocean
because a hurricane took him out and no
one remembers him right we remember the
hits and not the misses the successes
and not the failures I mean Nick you
have to give give credit to Nick
cantinares because he was able as a
truck driver you know never forget that
to get access to a spacesuit
very difficult but he couldn't he was
able to convince some people to get him
his spacesuit and he he went all the way
up he was already high up until kid
injured you know this is this is
important yes yes
even he was at Trump altitude the door
was already open you know but he could
not disconnect the oxygen houses because
they were frozen
they were there were still oxygen houses
could not
disconnect them so now he had to remain
in the capsule they had to cut him loose
he was writing it down and when when he
landed his visor was open you know so he
he somewhere on the way down you know
he's right so he had the crack
um I think he he suffered a lack of
oxygen for a long time trying to do a
vegetable I think he'll he lived another
three months and then he died in
hospital it's a very tragic story but
you know I mean that that's the big
learning out of this is that's why we
were successful you always have to test
things you can never go from zero to
hero and that's why we had a long
ongoing program you know we have been at
field Air Force Base did a lot of
chamber testing we have been at
Sacramento this is where they train all
the space shuttle guys well if I
remember I caught part of the live the
live they were we were moving back and
forth between images of you and some
control center if I remember correctly
wasn't there a bunch of people like at
base camp monitoring everything about
you yeah
Mission Control Joe kiddinger wasn't
there
um okay guiding me all the way up but he
was in charge it was Capcom one and he
was guiding me all the way up there's a
lot of scientists around and if there's
a problem
Joe talks to the scientists the
scientist tells him what to do and then
Joe talks to me again so the only person
talking to me was joking sure but
everybody around was supporting job I I
hate to burst your bubble here but yes
everyone in Mission Control wanted you
alive but the eight million people who
watched you
some percentage of them
they're they're saying is he going to
die you know you know this just I don't
want to be the first to break this news
to you it's it's the old Coliseum way of
thinking you know the editors the
Colosseum the same way you know right if
they survive great but you're really
there to watch them die right and then
if they survive they're they're here no
I'm I'm very very aware of that but you
know I don't really care because you
know that's why we did such a long
ongoing research you know and
development
to make sure that's not going to happen
do you uh you the way you've described
your life in these brief moments we've
had together it's as though like yes in
the last 10 years you haven't stopped
you're still jumping off of things where
you could have just did the elevator to
take the elevator or going home and
staying on the couch right we okay we've
established
apparently not so is there is there
something in your bloodstream that
requires this level of suspense and risk
taking whereas if you don't do it
somehow you're you'll just explode for
not putting your life at risk it's not
them that I'm explode but you know um
it's it's probably my DNA because the
way how I've been raised my dad is
Carpenter my mother was a housewife my
brother became a chef so it's not in the
family you know
yeah clearly not it's really not into
family but even as a kid you know I was
always climbing trees from a very early
age on
and I always like to see the world from
above the bird view you know but it's of
course as a kid you're you're very
limited on doing things you know but
that's the reason why I started because
your parents are trying to keep you
alive did you did you get the message
there this is the way from all the fun
job of the Paris okay don't fault them
for that all right uh so but let me
return to the point of philosophy here
you are looking at Earth from a very
different place are you distracted by
the details of the mission or did you
have a time to just reflect on that
moment all right talk with them like I
said you know it was so much work to
reach that point it took me from from
age of 17 all the way to 50 43 yeah and
then I'm standing there on top of the
world knowing that now it's a step under
the unknown so it's trying to embrace
that moment it was trying to inhale it
you know because it took us so much work
to get there
and I was standing outside and it's it's
completely silent you know there's no
noise up there all I could hear is
myself breathing then you look up you
see black sky
so it's a very interesting moment very
peaceful in one way but at the same time
you know that you have a mission to
accomplish well just remind people you
are high enough in the atmosphere in the
daytime that there's hardly any air
molecules above you to turn the sky blue
so the sun is out and you have a black
Sky I just want to clarify that for
anyone who wasn't following very good
explanation yeah and it was interesting
because I've never seen
during daylight black Sky yeah first
time in my life took me 50 years to
figure that out
yeah I wanted to stay there a little
longer to embrace that moment once you
disconnect your oxygen hoses from the
ship system from my capsule I only have
10 minutes of oxygen left from my
bailout bottles you know that's what my
team told me Felix do not overdo it we
know you want to stay there you want to
enjoy that moment but we really have to
press on because you need that oxygen on
the way down no time to do a happy dance
you can't do it happening no no nothing
you know whatever one minute I probably
one minute I enjoyed the few and
everything else trying to put that in my
memory for the rest of my life and then
I had to do this one step forward into
the unknown okay so I think you should
donate your body to I hope you live a
long natural life and donate your body
to the met the medicine and have them
investigate what's coursing through your
veins because it's not it's in so few
other people out there or do some slices
of your brain what the hell is wrong
with this guy uh or may or maybe it's
not what's wrong with him but what's
right with him because without people
such as yourself I mean I I count you as
extreme among those who take risks but
in the category of Risk Takers without
them we might still just be in the cave
saying no it's dangerous out there
outside the door no you make me some
points my friend
I'm just thinking that we are where we
are not because everyone is a daredevil
but some of us are showing the way so
that because some risks bring huge
rewards a cultural spiritual emotional
and so let me just publicly thank you on
behalf of our fan base and and others
for just reminding us of what what is
possible to achieve Just Being Human I
appreciate that a lot I mean just think
about the Wright Brothers Auto phone
linental you know all these people
people when it happens when somebody has
an idea and starts everybody's looking
at these people like what is wrong with
these people and maybe 50 years later we
understand and now we all can fly to
different places we catch up with them
we catch up with them yeah we catch up
with them but it takes somebody to pave
the way to do the first steps so others
can follow lead so others can follow it
dreamers always win I wish I was there
in person to shake your hand but good
luck and we all hope you lead a long
life and and face a natural death at the
end of it nothing premature
um uh you're part of our pop culture uh
understanding now and I don't want to
think of it as daredeviling as much as
what are the limits and let's just see
what the limits are of what we can
accomplish you know it's not direct
leveling because if you look at all my
background you know and all the
investigations that we do like I said
you know this was a huge ongoing program
never wanted to go from Zero to Hero
history that's that's the reason why I
always fight against the term Daredevil
you know I'm a risk manager risk
assessment it's one of my big topics
that's what I'm doing you control the
risks so that in fact you're not you're
not a daredevil at all you
exactly right
you got it okay okay Felix let me just
say I have to say because otherwise
people will get on my case I have
publicly criticized the phrase edge of
space because as an astrophysicist I
know it's space where it is yeah so so
I've shown people relative to a school
room Globe how far up your jump was
about a millimeter above the a school
room globe and so relative to space
that's very close but if you're standing
there at that location that's everything
so I just want to make sure we spent our
half hour celebrating that fact but
um the edge of space I'm thinking space
no
is 100 kilometers at least that I don't
really know Neil let me just finish this
where this is coming from because we
most of the time say you know jump from
the stratosphere yep that's okay yeah
exactly and then sometimes it it it went
South you know I don't know if it's the
meteor or something you know yeah yeah
always put you on a different pedestal
that I I never wanted to be there
people's always said jump from the
stratosphere but they made it to the
edge of space you know then it's hard to
fight back because now you're not
fighting against it because how you know
right right of course of course you got
it dude
I always stick to the truth we'll be the
judge of that no we've got you uh dude
it's been Delight to have you on Star
Talk our fan base will will Delight in
this conversation on the 10th
anniversary and a fast shout out to Red
Bull for for for tracking you through
this sponsors make so much happen in
this world and just give them a shout
out as well all right this has been Star
Talk a special addition to celebrating
the 10th anniversary of Felix
bumgardner's stratospheric jump where he
actually went supersonic okay and he's
still okay he's like alive all right
good job and happy as always all right
Felix if you can jump from the Moon to
Earth we'll bring it back on the show
and we'll talk some more all right we're
gonna break the speed of Lights the next
time oh there you go that's it that's it
all right dude keep it real see you my
friend
[Music]
thank you